the jurgen experience are there are
there any guests that you've yet to have
that would be sort of here are my top
three i
i know you recently had kanye west uh
what are some people that you think sort
of are are you know you must have them
before this whole ride
ends none zero i don't have that thought
yeah i mean even
even yeah even kanye um i mean i get
i guess i should probably say this i
kind of avoided talking to him for a
long time because i was worried it was
going to be
not good for him because i'm such a fan
of his as an
artist i think he's a brilliant musician
but i also think that
because of his i mean he's been
diagnosed as being bipolar i mean
whatever you want to say
whatever mental issues he's had i think
they
contribute in some ways to his art
because he's so prolific
his mind is going in a million different
directions all at once
and someone who is like that but very
different of course is elon musk
his mind is going in a million different
directions all at the same time as well
and
his his ability to
focus on so many different subjects
simultaneously is stunning kanye is the
same way
but in a different realm right his focus
is on
design and on rap and on
now uh religion i mean he's become very
religious
and and even politics but he's very
misunderstood
kanye is a very misunderstood person and
i i think that
he doesn't do himself any service by
calling himself a genius and
and all the the all but all the
that all the trump stuff similar to
trump right
he's kind of you know he pats himself on
the back and pumps himself up and talks
about
his accomplishments and his financial
success and all those different
for whatever reason those put some
people off they don't put me off but
they did they do put some people off
but i understand why he does it i
understand that he's
he's kind of looking to affirm that he's
on the right path
like he like these are markers of
success that he could point to
like you can say he's an idiot you could
say all these different things but hey
look at all he's accomplished
look at what he's done and if you listen
to his music
i mean he's brilliant there's no doubt
about he's brilliant he's insanely
prolific
and his stuff is great he's never put
out a bad album they're all great
and he's married to an armenian woman
as is your good friend godzilla so
that's a commonality that we both share
episodes of the joe rogan experience are
now free on spotify
that's right they're free from september
1st to december 1st they're going to be
available everywhere but after december
1st they will only be
available on spotify but they will be
free that includes the video the video
will also be there
it'll also be free that's all we're
asking just go
download spotify much love